[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis vous vous
êtes bien amusé aujourd'hui avec tous
vos nouveaux jouets et que se passe-t-il
chez nicolas et pimprenelle il y a
beaucoup de bruit on les entends d'ici
au patron je descend vite
pourvu que mes petits neveux va vite
voir nounours et dealers de ne pas faire
autant de bruit le up bon l'ujtl hop hop
hop hop on tient là haut le vis pas
comme ça fâche un bon jour les ans au
fait qu'est ce qui se passe comment il
s'entraînerait ils sont toujours très
mignon c'est petit et c'est très mignon
seulement voilà la puce
mais ce n'est rien du tout ça tous les
jours sont en nous c'est un signe de
bonne santé
maman a dit pas ça ils nous on en a
jamais bon on va l'aider toyer enfants
montre tête rue ou la grosse puce
ça y est tu les oreilles un petit coup
de frein a été très bon comme safran
hoyaux at-il tourbe
aux jeux sont encore cachés tout ou
totaux te donnerai un fou qui prouve
miel si tu viens de faire enlever tpu
tient le voilà ton vivant pour tiens
nous nous retirons thierno lô duquel
tout soit ça après tout rien ne peut pas
il c'est fini rémy coup rémy demain on
leur donnera un bon buzz fiche de
trappes
il est aussi qu'aucun que son frère
william et kate qui tient la trouver
[Musique]
l' attaque tout est un des coups de
brosse au une grosse peluche et elle a
sauté
moussa pas j'en sais rien eh bien les
voilà propre tous les 300 ha ben non on
va se coucher qui vient tapera mais
wilko la bonne nuit de noce chéri
[Musique]
oh
mais mais ces petits anges il faut les
endormir en chan plus immergé on ne
verse appelé 28 nov
bon allons venez petits trésors votre
tonton pas s'occuper de nous
[Musique]
faire mon bien les pompiers
oh
bonsoir papa maman ge
j'ai éteint les lumières
euros
chez les petits enfants
j'ouvre la fenêtre je sens andouille les
ensembles tels
sont endormis
je reprends bonne échelle
l'eau
je connais
ce moment
[Musique]
nicolas
et
je
l'outil a tort
[Musique]
et
à te voilà enfin nounours tu as été bien
long ce soir bonne nuit les enfants fait
bien sagement votre toilette embrasser
bien fort vos parents et aller vite au
dodo allons fidèle compagnon arrête de
te gratter en route
à demain un dôme un bon début
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]